-We love our audience.
You watch us every night.
But right now, we want to change
things up and watch you.
We asked you guys at home
to send us some fun
or unique talents that you have.
We got submissions
from thousands of people
all across the world.
And we're going to meet
some of them now.
It is time for
"Show Me Something Good."
-♪ Show me something good ♪
♪ Show me something good ♪
♪ Show me ♪
-Alright.
Let's meet our first guest.
Hello. Come on over.
Hi.
-Hi.
-Nice to see you.
-Nice to meet you.
-Thanks for being here.
-No problem.
Thanks for having me.
-What is your name,
and where you from?
-My name is Ajiea Hargrave.
I'm originally from
Reading, Pennsylvania,
but I live in L.A. now.
-Hey, L.A.
There you go. Come on.
And, Ajiea, what talent will you
be sharing with us tonight?
-So, I was gonna do a back tuck
and put these shorts on midair.
-So, wait, you're gonna
do a back tuck,
which is a flip, right?
-Yep.
-A back tuck
and put the shorts on midair.
-Yep.
-I'm ready to see this.
Do you need anything?
Can I help you?
-Yeah. Actually, I'm gonna
need a trampoline.
-We got a trampoline
right there.
-Oh, okay, good.
-Ajiea, whenever you're ready.
-Alright.
-I'm gonna stand back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drum roll ]
Here we go.
Come on.
Come on!
[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Yes!
That is how you do it!
Come on, now!
-Thank you.
-That is how you do it.
Can we see that --
Can we see that in slow motion?
Whoa, yes!
Come on. Fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you so much.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Now let's meet our next guest.
Come on over here.
Hello. Hey.
What is your --
Thanks for being here.
-Nice to meet you.
-Well, what is your name
and where are you from?
-Mada Graviet.
I live in Salt Lake City, Utah.
From Richmond, Virginia.
-Hey. Alright.
-Yeah.
-Now, Mada,
I saw what you're gonna do,
but I don't want to spoil it
and ruin it for anyone.
So, do you just want to just
walk us through and just --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Just leave it at that.
But get ready
to have your mind blown.
-Something like that.
You said talent.
It's more of a party trick.
-Yeah.
-All you need
is Fruit by the Foot.
-Okay. Fruit by the Foot.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
-One good nostril.
-Not an ad.
Not an ad.
-Not yet.
-No.
-Okay.
Start off like this.
-Okay, Fruit by the Foot.
-Yeah, only one way
to open them.
-That's correct.
Oh, that's it.
-Yeah.
-That's the one, yeah.
-So, you don't really need
the treat,
but it's fun to munch on
while you're rolling it up.
-Okay.
So, yeah, so...
-We'll just place that
right there.
But that doesn't do us any good.
-So, the fruit goes there.
-Yeah.
You start with this.
This little -- the rolled side.
-The rolled side, yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
You're just gonna take it.
-Okay.
-Gonna start rolling it up.
-Takes a minute, though.
-Oh, yeah, go for it.
Take your time.
-Rolled some for us, though.
-Oh, you have some rolled.
-I got some rolled.
It definitely --
It takes a sec.
So, I got some
pre-rolled for us.
-Pre-rolled
Fruit by the Foot roll.
Yeah. Alright.
So, thank you. Pre-rolled.
-So take it like this.
Poor word choice.
-It's legal now in New York,
so it's fine.
-I know. Whenever I started
this, people were like,
"What kind of party trick
are you doing there?"
-So, you have this.
Yeah, sure.
-Pick a nostril.
-Okay.
-Kinda gotta...
[ Drum roll ]
Sometimes you got to
let it simmer for a sec,
make sure it's really in there.
Once it's in there good...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can -- I can do better
if we want to try.
-No. Let's try --
Here, let's try one together.
-Let's do it.
-Can I do one?
Just take this.
Any nostril?
-You might --
One three. Oh.
That's pretty good!
That's probably
better than mine.
Better than mine.
-[ Laughs ]
You taught me.
The student has now
become the teacher.
-Yeah.
-Thank you, Mada.
What a talent.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now let's meet our final guest.
Come on over, bud.
Oh, yeah, I know
what I'm talking about.
That's --
Thank you very much.
-What's up, Jimmy?
-I appreciate the sleeves.
Thanks for being here tonight.
What is your name
and where you from?
-I'm John McVicker, and I'm
from Trenton, New Jersey.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
-Believe it or not.
Believe it or not.
-I got to see your talent,
and I'm a fan.
What will you be showing us
tonight, John?
-Well, I'm definitely
not going to the moon.
I'm gonna be doing some
car sounds for you tonight.
-Mm-hmm, car sounds?
-Right.
-Right. Okay.
-With my mouth.
-With your mouth.
So you'll be making sounds
like you're driving a --
What type of car, do you think?
-Do you like Formula 1?
-Yeah, I do. F1, sure.
Absolutely.
-Yeah, that's the sound
I'm gonna do for you.
-You do a little F1?
-Yeah.
-Alright,
we have a chair, right?
You have your helmet?
-Oh, you got a chair?
-Yeah, I have a chair over there
you can sit in.
-That's a nice F1 car.
-Yeah.
You can go head over there
and put your helmet on.
-Yeah, safety first, everyone.
-Safety first.
Yeah, you're not
driving anywhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
John, this is very exciting.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
-[ Imitates clicking ]
[ Imitating racecar engine ]
Oh, he passed me!
-He can't hear you.
That's incredible, John!
John!
That's how you do it.
Get over here, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it, buddy.
Thank you so much, bud.
I appreciate it.
They're making that F1 movie.
You should be in that.
Let's call Brad Pitt right now.
Let's get all our talented
performers over here right now.
Come on.
That's all the time we have
for "Show Me Something Good."
Whoa!
If you have a fun talent,
I want to see it.
Go to tonightshow.com/
showmesomethinggood.
Submit a video.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with Ice-T,
everybody.
What are you doing?
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪